SPEAKER 1: Stuck
right in the middle
of this beautiful,
serene water sits
this brown, stark, brick
building which is either
the ugliest resort in
the world, or some kind
of mini Alcatraz-- a place
built to keep people in.
Which, it is.
This place actually once held
one of America's most famous
prisoners.
The person who took this
aerial shot is this man.
STEVE RICH: Hi, my
name's Steve Rich.
I'm from Aiken, South Carolina,
and I enjoy photography
as a hobby.
These photos were taken on a
flight from Key West, Florida
to Fort Jefferson,
Dry Tortugas, in April
of 2010 while on a small private
plane flying over the island.
Access to the island can only
be done by sea plane or by boat.
Our plane was not equipped
for landing on the water,
so I enjoyed an afternoon of
picture taking from there.
SPEAKER 1: Now for a
quick geography lesson
to make it clear
just went Steve was.
These are the Dry
Tortugas, a small group
of islands about 70 miles
off the coast of Key West,
Florida, that the US purchased
from Spain in the early 1800s.
It was named by none other
than Ponce de Leon in 1513.
STEVE RICH: Tortugas
means turtles in Spanish.
The name Dry Tortugas was
later given to the island
to indicate to other mariners
that the land mass lacked
fresh water, which was an
extremely important detail
to seafarers to know.
SPEAKER 1: And now for
your history lesson.
Dry Tortugas is one of
the smallest and most
remote national parks, that not
only protects the reef islands
and sea life, but also
these historic shipwrecks.
And this place, Fort Jefferson.
It was built as a strategically
placed military fort
to combat piracy
in the Caribbean
that was never
completed, and eventually
ended up as a military
prison after the Civil War.
And it once held a
very notorious man.
STEVE RICH: Fort Jefferson's
most famous prisoner,
Doctor Samuel Mudd,
left his historical mark
on the Dry Tortugas.
He is most infamously
known for his involvement
in the assassination of
President Abraham Lincoln, who
was shot by John Wilkes Booth.
During his assassination
of the President,
John Wilkes Booth broke
his leg and sought
the help of Doctor Mudd, who
stayed at Mudd's residence
until the next day.
Doctor Mudd was later
arrested for conspiracy
and for harboring Mr. Booth.
Doctor Mudd was
convicted and sentenced
to life imprisonment at Fort
Jefferson in the Dry Tortugas.
SPEAKER 1: However,
there was a happy ending
for Doctor Mudd, who was
pardoned by President Andrew
Johnson.
But maybe an even happier
ending for the fort itself
and the islands and marine
life that surround them.
STEVE RICH: Seeing the
many islands from the air
was truly amazing.
We saw sharks,
stingrays, shipwrecks.
Fort Jefferson is part of
our National Park Service
and represents what really is
special to the American people.
I feel like our park
service takes great pride
in preserving historical
areas of our great country.
SPEAKER 1: Want to see
more mysterious places
from around the world?
Check out this episode
on the wild side
of Yellowstone National Park.
Or watch this one on the
world's largest tree house.
And don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.